all right valentina
yes valentino where are you from where'd
you grow up uh
i grew up in miami um up until i was 18
and then i left to new york as soon as i
could
and you're living in los angeles
currently yeah i've been out here for
the past
five years or so and tell me about your
childhood you had both your parents when
you were young
uh yeah i had both of my parents
um
they divorced when i was 18. they did
that thing where like they never liked
each other but they stayed together
because they had kids
and yeah but i had both of them
i still do how would you describe your
childhood
um they did the best
that they could given the
given the tools that they had and um
yeah i think that's a good way of seeing
it yeah
um i mean i don't like blame them for
anything
um my mom was always
angry so even my dad would be like
scared of her
um she would yell a lot and
but besides that i mean i just got like
the
i would get hit but i mean nothing like
out of the
nothing terrible no nothing too terrible
yeah no and
what kind of kid were you in high school
oh i was bad
i was i was really bad um
yeah in high school i guess i don't know
the hormones and also
miami's i don't think is like the best
place to raise a child
i would say is a lot of drugs and
yeah so in high school i experimented a
lot with drugs and
i had a lot of sex
but i would skip class i
didn't finish high school around 16 i
was like i'm gonna join the military i
thought that would be a good idea
so i didn't follow through with that i
got an
argument with the recruiter and then
that was it
but um i got my ged and then
i tried college uh
but yeah high school this bad i
tried um first it was weed
then i tried coke and then i did uh
acid shrooms pills ever pretty much
everything except like the hard stuff
i never i never wanted to get lost and i
was scared of getting lost
so but thankfully i don't have like a
addictive personality so
nothing stuck yeah and today you're just
doing
uh pot you said uh yeah like a couple
times a year
okay for like celebratory words are not
really a part of your life now no
uh maybe like two glasses of wine a week
or something like that yeah
and what kind of work have you done
since uh since school
uh everything so
waitressing stripping
i went to school for two years and i
became an ultrasound tech
so i'm currently doing that during the
day
um but yeah i've i've had
probably over 30 jobs at this point so
you have a straight job yeah as an
ultrasound tech
yeah and then what do you do with your
other free your
when you're not working that job school
i'm in school and then also
i see men on the side uh
professional men i guess yeah so this is
through like
websites and things like that yeah so
you would call yourself an escort
uh i'd call myself a sex worker but yeah
essentially it's
escorting right sex worker is such a
vague term that i have a hard time using
it
well because i've gone through other
mediums or ways i just
because i've done stripping and
webcaming and
escorting and sometimes just uh just
straight up prostitution i mean not like
on the street but
yeah so i just say sex work because i've
done it all
how does stripping compare to working as
an escort uh
so with stripping you have to
you have to have a good mouthpiece i
would say and
i don't have that i i'd rather
the person knows what they want i know
what i want and then we just
we just get it over with and go home our
separate ways with stripping you're
there
five at least five hours and i would
come out of there
with maybe six hundred dollars but
that's also because i wasn't like
um doing anything in the back
i guess i was just dancing mostly
because i didn't want to talk a lot of
girls will do things
in the back rooms yeah all the time yeah
i worked in strip clubs in miami
and then also in new york
um the ones out here aren't really that
good so i never did it out here
but um yeah it's it's tiring and
exhausting
it wears on your body and everyone's
smoking
you just go home and you feel like [ __ ]
the next day
um yeah so uh
with escorting it's it's a quick one
hour and it's the same
money like i have a minimum like i won't
leave unless it's 500
preferably more than that but for an
hour and then i go home and
i don't have to think about it until
next week so
are there dangers in working
as an escort where you're probably
picking up a higher caliber of
customer than than working the street um
yeah working the street i've never
considered doing
right that's another i never felt like i
had to
so i mean everyone does
things because they feel like they have
to do it like if i ever felt like i had
to i would
i would but i think that's a much more
treacherous lifestyle than what you're
doing
yeah for sure um but are there dangers
in what you're doing as well
um i've only had one
terrible experience like it wasn't even
that i mean i got drugged
but um nothing
worse than that um
yeah or how would you describe most of
your clientele
uh
rich old white men that um they either
have their own businesses
or um engineers you know just
they're normal they're just lonely are
they married
some of them yeah um
i actually ended up having like a
three-year relationship with one like a
a normal romantic relationship you
actually liked him and he liked you
yeah um he was married
uh had kids and everything so
it's not like we were like going in with
those expectations but that's just what
happened was it a sugar daddy
relationship
yeah it was so you didn't truly
i mean it's a fine line and it gets
blurred all the time where
were you in love with him were you no we
were in love we lived together
and everything uh
he was just helping me out with like 2
000 a month that's not enough to like
make me stay
you know like i gave up a lot of things
that would mean i've got about
30 of those kind of relationships going
right now yeah
what uh and where do you see your life
going from here
um well like i said i'm in school so
graduate school um
that's a good question i mean i don't i
try not to think too much hold you
i'm 25. 25. so you're very young and
you're yeah
you can go in any direction from here
but
this lifestyle that you're living i mean
what what what comes along with it are
there emotions that it brings up or is
there
ah when you're when you're by yourself
do you sometimes
have feelings that come from this doing
this kind of work
only if
only during usually not when i'm by
myself when i'm by myself i like to like
compartmentalize like i'm like that's
what i do
for money because i'm only doing that
because with my job i make enough to
like support myself
and live a normal life i guess are you
saving money
uh i'm trying to but the thing is i take
care of my mom
and then i also take care of my sister
so i'm like financially supporting
between your job and your side job yeah
supporting three people so um
yeah so i'm trying to save money but
it's impossible
yeah life gets expensive yeah
does your family know you're doing this
um
i think my dad knows that i was
stripping
but no so now you're gonna do a video on
youtube
yeah i'm trying to
live more openly i guess and honestly
and i don't think that
i mean they would prefer i wouldn't of
course but um
i think they just love me and your
motive seems to be to
help support your family yeah mainly
which is noble
right yeah i'm not out here buying like
louis vuitton bags and driving a bmw or
anything like that
it's just um what i feel like i have to
do
right but i mean it does get in the way
of uh
me having like a normal relationship i
guess
does it mm-hmm i would think most
guys that might want a relationship with
you would have a hard time with you
doing that
at night some guys don't mind yeah i'm
sure there's
and there's always exceptions to
everything i say yeah uh some guys don't
mind
but um yeah it's not like an ideal
situation
yeah i i would think i'd have a hard
time if you're if you're my girlfriend
and you're going off to
entertain three guys tonight well if
i'm only seeing currently i'm only
seeing one person
once a week uh but sometimes
i have like i guess regulars that
they'll like come
come and go they'll yeah they'll just
like text me randomly and then
maybe in a month i'll see like three
guys that's it
yeah is there shame that comes up from
this
uh yeah sex work and shame seem to go
together
so i'm not saying there should be
i'm sure people
i'm sure people think whatever they want
of me
but um i don't
feel that way yeah you just feel like
you're doing what you have to do to
survive
yeah yeah pretty much and it's not like
uh i'm stealing or robbing or you know
like tricking anyone into anything no
you're
providing a service and yeah
it's an agreement on both sides right
yeah
do you respect the guys that pick you up
um well i'm in school for psychology so
you are yeah so from like the human
perspective
i try to understand and respect them to
an extent
as far as like you know they're lonely
they have
whatever issues they have going on like
i i hear them out i'm
like their therapist sometimes sure but
um
give guys that pick you up and will not
watch sex they just want to have have
a couple hours with you guys always want
sex i do
i get so many girls that tell me the
guys don't want sex and i'm like really
they have a good mouthpiece probably i i
don't know
i mean i'm i'm an amazing listener but
um
no everyone wants to have sex i think um
what was the question no just uh
do i respect them do you respect the men
that that are your customers
uh from a yeah from a human perspective
i do
but as far as myself no like you
wouldn't want them for partners
god no they're disgusting
like um
yeah i don't respect people who can't be
like
honest with themselves yeah
like it's one thing to lie to your wife
and lie to your friends or whatever but
they're lying just lying to themselves
so yeah they're nasty like they're just
um
yeah i don't know no the answer is the
clear answer is no yeah i sense that
do you believe in love uh
i believe in love you do yeah uh i don't
think that love just
is is just one like soul definition
i like the people i love the most would
be my sister number one and then
probably my mom
my mom and i have just been through a
lot
particularly like after
after her separation from like my dad
she ended up losing
her her dad her mom and her best friend
like around the same time
and then she lost the house she lost her
job
and then she just like lost her mind
her sanity pretty much
she's uh she's always been like
schizophrenic like i remember
when i was younger she would she would
tell me like
that i had special eyes and that i can
like look at the sun for like a really
long time
yeah and she would um she would just
do some weird stuff but for the most
part it was like under control
uh but then after the divorce like
uh yeah she lost everything she like
attempted suicide multiple times
i like left new york to come stay with
her
to like take care of her and uh the
first night we got like a
an apartment she like jumped off of the
second floor
uh like right in front of me yeah that
that really messed me up for a long time
[Music]
uh but
yeah she she's older so she broke like
her hip and had to get multiple
surgeries
and she's been in and out of like mental
hospitals
for the past uh seven years i guess
yeah so
but the way that it's affected me i
guess um
[Music]
i've kind of just been
following like her i guess her footsteps
in a way
like uh not as schizophrenia no
not as far as i'm concerned but um uh
in october i ended up going to the
psychiatric
ward for like a suicide attempt and
[Music]
yeah just like a lot of generational
depression in my family
i would say do you think that's like
just brain chemistry or is it something
that
i think so yeah because the first time i
felt depressed i was like in fourth
grade
um i just remember like crying in my
room and i couldn't like
explain like why i was crying there was
no reason behind it i was just sad
the more i do these talks the more i see
that brain chemistry is a
big part of the puzzle yeah of
everything that you hear these
people struggling with all of us yeah
um yeah so i think
uh yeah i've had depression for the most
part in my life
now it's it's okay because after i went
to the hospital they put me on
medication so it's
i'm doing better
does this work you do affect you do you
think
um i mean does it make you does it make
depression more
make you more prone to feeling depressed
i mean if you believe in love
but then you're selling yourself for
money
at some point there's a conflict there
that comes up it is difficult because i
i appreciate that you said like selling
yourself and not just your body because
it is like you're selling your time
you're selling
uh like a part of your soul in a way
i didn't want to say those words but
that's kind of what i'm yeah referring
to
um
yeah uh i guess it does and like the
more you
i mean i work i work as a photographer
for advertising so when i do that
for money as i did yesterday i feel like
i'm selling myself mm-hmm
just like a an escort would be selling
herself we're all prostituted
i i totally see that and and i believe
it's all the same thing
yeah um
yeah i mean it does affect me
negatively i would say uh but i have
reasons and i have you know like that's
why i
i suggest like anyone who's looking to
do
this like to actually have like
maybe not a career but like an actual
job and like something to look forward
to and like
positive people in your life because do
you enjoy your
your day job um
i do because i like helping people like
i like
that human connection um
uh but it's not like what i want to do
for the rest of my life for sure
uh yeah my goal is to be a therapist so
that's great
yeah just because i mean
i've been around like crazy people and
broken individuals my whole life
including myself so yeah i think we all
are
yeah we all just demonstrate it in
different ways and the ones who deny it
are the ones that are probably the worst
the worst off yeah i think everyone
needs therapy
like at least at one point in their life
for whatever period that
is but um it's very at least for me it's
been very helpful
what have you learned about men by doing
this kind of work the
sex work uh
not much to be honest with you i've
actually it's not all men that do this
that that will hire a prostitute
um it's only a certain segment of the
popular
i feel like i've known men my whole life
like
it's not you don't learn anything that
you don't already know um
yeah uh one of the interviews i did last
week one of the i asked the girls
the girl this question she said men are
dogs that's what i learned
uh uh yeah some but some are loyal you
know some some are loyal i'm sure some
are yeah
some are loyal some are cuter than
others some you know won't hump you in
your sleep
but for the most part yeah i guess yeah
it's a wide range yeah i've learned that
but i just you know because you work as
an escort and have this background
it's it's an interesting it's just
interesting to get your perspective on
it
yeah no i i had an introduction to men
at a very
uh young age like the
i don't know if it's the sole reason but
like i guess my introduction to like
sex work started at like 12 pretty much
how'd that happen
um i had a best friend in middle school
uh her dad at the time i was like 12 and
he was like
uh i don't know like in his 50s maybe or
like late 40s or something like that
he you want like the full start
well i mean share as much as you you're
comfortable sharing sure i mean it's
just like
you can simplify it if that happens okay
i mean it's just like 10 years of stuff
oh really yeah but i can the sexual
relationship with your friend's dad
uh we only had sex one time but um
yeah like he met me and i guess pretty
much like fell in love with me
and he was being
sentenced to prison he lived in
california and i was in miami and
uh he
came down to see his daughter and i
might not be getting all the details
right so i
like of their part but from my
perspective this is what happened
and um he was being sentenced to prison
so he wanted to see her like one last
time because he was going to go for
three years or four years whatever it
was he met me
on his birthday which is october 1st
and i say this because october 1st just
a lot of stuff happens on october 1st
for some reason for me
so i meet him he falls in love with me
essentially we maintain
touch for like so i can keep him updated
on
his daughter or whatever he ends up like
calling me we talk on the phone all the
time he would send me like love letters
from prison
from prison from prison yeah he would
send me poems and stuff
then he got out
[Music]
we maintained touch he would fly back
and forth to like come see me
i think i was like 16 and this was like
the time i was gonna go to the military
so
he like got a hotel for us and bought me
like all this lingerie
and i just felt like really
uncomfortable because like i i
i didn't like i wasn't attracted to him
i didn't like
feel that for him but at the time i felt
like
i don't know i felt kind of
trapped like i didn't have any like
choices
really because he was scary like he
ended up getting um
like my name my initials like my lips a
portrait of me like tattooed on him he
has like my mom's initials like he's not
like a sane person um
but this all began not sexually but the
the
the romantic part of it for him sounded
like it started when you were 12.
yeah he would like ask me for like nudes
and stuff
and i was like fifty dollars
like i would sell him my nudes for like
fifty dollars
and um at the time like that's a lot of
money for like uh
i guess i was like 14 at this time or
15. um
yeah but back to the the night with the
hotel i and i just felt trapped and he
was like okay that's fine we can go home
i'll take you home but my parents didn't
know i was with him obviously so i'm
like no
i can't go home like i have to stay and
yeah we had sex um
for like a minute and then i started
crying uh
and in my mind i was just like
not that i deserve this but i guess like
in a way like i get i put myself in this
situation like no one told me to do this
like i'm
i'm here like i guess um
i guess this is what i deserve i guess
like
it's the way that my mind like would you
say it was your environment was it your
brain chemistry was it something that
happened in your childhood
what would you say open the door for
that or was it just
or he just pressured you or pursue you
know pursued you so heavily
yeah he would just make me feel bad like
make me like manipulate me
into
into feeling like this is what i yeah
that's that's what it kind of sounds
like yeah because he was like 50
something and i was like
15. but um
yeah and then fast forward
he would send letters to my dad's house
and like
you know send bouquets like
edible arrangements to like my job and
like just show up and
um when i got in that relationship with
that
man that turned into a three-year
relationship uh
he helped me like get a restraining
order because i just couldn't do it like
in my mind i was like i can't like he's
gonna go back to prison like something's
gonna happen to like
it was like a a weird dynamic like where
i didn't want him to get in trouble like
i cared for him even though like
he was threatening me all the time
and
stalking me whatever i don't know what
it's called but yeah
just making my life very difficult
being an attractive female has its
burdens doesn't it
i don't consider myself uh
attractive like you don't no i like
consider myself neutral i guess because
i'm just myself and
this is i mean i definitely
use it to my advantage to get money
and whatever right but um
like when i go home and like take my
makeup off and i'm just there by myself
like i'm not like oh
i'm so pretty you don't see yourself
that way no
i just see myself as normal like a
person
that's probably a healthy attitude but
it yeah but you are beautiful and you
thank you you should see yourself what's
the most important lesson you've learned
in your life
um
i mean i had a negative view of life for
up until a couple months ago so i guess
just to be present like i right now i'm
not thinking like
when i leave here or i'm not thinking
like before
i'm just like right now this is what's
happening and uh
yeah just trying to be present that's
great yeah that's a great one
thanks all right vantina thank you so
much for sharing your story
thank you and i wish you the best of
luck with with school and
in your two careers thank you so much
thank you that's great
you